here's the deal over the course of the
last several months the nba 2k
community has allegedly been scammed out
of an amount
up to 200 000 nba 2k
is massively popular online and
according to allegations from multiple
community members
that popularity may have been used to
exploit people
for money
[Music]
alright guys if you have an idea for a
story that you'd love to see covered on
this channel
why don't you subscribe ring the
notification bell and let us know in the
comments down below
we're always looking for interesting
stories from across esports and gaming
alright back to 2k okay so let me take
you back to where this all started there
are a lot of ways to play
nba 2k and one that's gained popularity
is wager matches
where people put up money on a game but
wagers aren't really the issue here
when some community members came forward
claiming that they were owed wager money
from a content creator called step back
rack
others started to investigate rack had
apparently been around the australia new
zealand
2k scene since late nba 2k20
but when the complaint started content
creator ticino
decided to dig deeper according to
multiple alleged victims
the missing wager money may just be the
start estimates by ticino note that the
community may have been scammed
out of up to two hundred thousand
dollars between the missing wager money
but also a scam to flip short-term money
for huge profits let me explain to you
exactly how this scamming was taking
place
alleged victims were told that the money
was being used by
another person calvin bai to gamble and
create returns
but that the transfers would look
suspicious to buy's wife
if they came from rack's account the
allegations paint a picture that looks
like
classic ponzi scheme or potentially
pyramid scheme
territory you pay out some early
investors to build confidence
but then you get bigger and bigger sums
which you keep
completely offsetting those initial
losses with that in mind
on september 20th many people came
forward with experiences
that resembled this kind of scam one
user named it's pack boy
claimed that he had been scammed by rack
and posted a ton of screenshots that
appeared to show a discussion about the
alleged scheme
between himself and another 2k community
member called
range or eric lim the discussions are
about returns on money that was
allegedly being lended to iraq
who also use the name ben it's packboy
said that he trusted
range because he was a member of the
australian new zealand 2k community
what we see in screenshots is that range
appeared to be the one coordinating the
money
in the receipts he asked for money up
front promising quick returns
after a couple such transactions the
pressure for bigger money
escalates its pack boy screenshots
include receipts of him sending
three thousand dollars to an account
owned by someone named calvin bai
but with step back rack 2k as the
subject
a later message from range appears to
show him
pressuring people who were lending money
not to back out on future
opportunities after sending the money
the receipts show a long series of
promises
excuses and delays that led nowhere he
refers to rack as
ben and he was seemingly using that name
throughout this entire situation
as this screenshot from its pack boy
shows another user squoogs
alleged that not only did range scam him
he did it after sqoogs
actually sheltered range in his home
when he was kicked out by his family
even worse squoog estimates that the
amount scammed from the community
was actually upwards of three hundred
thousand dollars
but others have come forward with
accusations against iraq
including one who wasn't even involved
in 2k
so after the accusations rak dropped off
the face of the planet 2k
community members who were looking for
him found a facebook post with a comment
from someone called danny saleh it
accused rack
of withholding money danny saleh went to
school with rack
who he knows by the name quentin yap i
spoke with him about his experiences
which took place five years ago before
any of the 2k allegations started
according to saleh when he posted about
an upcoming trip to australia from his
home of malaysia
yap responded and offered to hang out so
they could catch up but when they met up
yap pitched him on investing in his
business
he also showed him his expensive car a
mercedes-benz
for investing in his business a convent
shop that imported goods from
asia sally said yap offered him a 40
return on 3 000 australian dollars over
a year
which is a lot and apparently said
that even greater amounts could net
greater returns
the discussions were initially verbal
but sally says that yap started texting
him about it
and eventually sent him a contract
sally's wife was skeptical
but he was enticed by the possibility
for greater returns on larger amounts
and he says he actually sent fifteen
thousand
the contract stated six thousand but
okay i signed it i sent it back to him
but he didn't send me back to me but he
said that he had
he's kind of had some issue or something
like that he never signed it
i i was stupid that i wasn't once it was
time to see some returns
sally said that he checked back with yap
as agreed
but he says yap told him that there was
a problem with the international bank
transfer
a problem that he could expedite if
saleh could send him some more money
so i was dumb enough to transfer him
into 3000
not transferred to him transferred to
his friend
in malaysia he gave me a malaysia
bank account i think you know where this
is going
but the transfer didn't help speed
things up sally ran up against a
different excuse
every time it went on about three months
he kept on saying that
his bank has issues or he's busy at work
he can't he can't go to the bank right
now
that's that's always an excuse every
single day
i asked him bro are you scamming me so i
got really really angry because
i really needed to use the money that
time and he just
his last text to me was like uh
you [ __ ] off i don't want to hear from
you anymore
that's it sally says he asked a friend
in australia to check up on yap at his
address
but when they arrived they were told
that there was no proof that
yap owed anything and based on the
emailed contract which yap
may never have signed he might be right
but while saleh says he
eventually gave up on trying to get his
money back
it had a profound impact on his life for
the past four years
it kind of like haunt me i couldn't
really sleep i was depressed
i was angry literally all the time
up until early this year after i went my
wife said please let go of everything
because i'm tired of hearing this i'm
tired of you being angry i'm tired of
you
acting off because i'm always angry i
could have used that money for something
else a lot of things
though saleh had given up hope he was
actually dragged back into the situation
by 2k community members who were trying
to figure out what happened with rack
and what sally told them sounded eerily
familiar
big returns promised on short-term money
like i said the allegations from both
saleh
and 2k community members like it's pack
boy
seem to point to a scam called a ponzi
scheme
the scheme uses some way to build
confidence with potential targets
screenshots seem to suggest that early
investors
actually got the returns they were
promised which helps to spread the word
that the scheme is legit but as amounts
increase
the delays and excuses start and the
pressure
mounts to keep people invested
eventually
the money doesn't come back and
investors are
out way more than they made initially
this screenshot from its pack boy
appears to show range threatening to cut
off people
who only go in for big returns or who
decide to drop
out completely this message is packed
with other warning signs
like congratulating people who don't
rely on returns from previous money
to invest more right now but having said
that
i'm not going to blame the victims were
there warning signs definitely
but some of these people were probably
minors and even still
if proven a ponzi scheme is illegal and
would be prosecuted in a court as fraud
and listen if you're sitting at home
thinking well these people fell
for it and don't they kind of deserve it
i can't say that i agree
what these people are alleging is still
illegal even if some people made some
bad decisions
with the unsigned contract that saleh
has
and the lack of legal documentation for
the 2k community members who put money
in
it might be difficult for them to find
justice or even a way to pursue it
rak or quens and yap has seemingly
disappeared
and range isn't saying anything about
the situation
neither responded to a request for
comment for this story
this water bottle is an hgc water bottle
uh yeah obviously heroes of the storm
rest in peace the
the top of this water bottle like broke
off a long time ago and now i'm just
like
it has no top so if you if you it just
pours out like watch
easy see like there's no tumbler i can
pour water on the carpet if i want to to
summarize i can do what i want in here
and
uh nobody can stop me except akuma yeah
yeah he can akuma does have some say as
to like what happens down here
for the most part it's just me and the
cat
um but yeah sometimes akuma chimes in
you know
he's a little bit gruff and he's not
super sociable but yeah it's
it's pretty good